justo antes del comienzo de este
discurso de Guillermo lasso hemos podido
hablar con la presidenta del cne que nos
ha confirmado a la cámara y al micrófono
de France 24 que el 20 de agosto será la
fecha para esas elecciones también esta
noche habrá una locución a la nación
donde se terminará de confirmar esa
fecha como repito 20 de agosto fecha de
las elecciones y de unas consultas
populares también sobre explotaciones
petrolíferas y minerales en unos parques
nacionales del país ahora espera una
carrera presidencial con mucho ajetreo y
en la que los partidos tendrán realmente
poco tiempo para presentar a esos
candidatos y para preparar Esta carrera
presidencial en la que como decía el 20
de agosto van a votar de nuevo los
ecuatorianos